quentin tarantino's once upon a time in
Hollywood is packed with 60s pop culture
references callbacks to his previous
films and other Easter eggs here's
everything you might have missed and
warning major spoilers ahead first off
the titles are reference to Sergio
Leone's films Once Upon a Time in the
West and Once Upon a Time in America
Leone is perhaps the most famous
director of spaghetti westerns and
Tarantino has not been shy about how
these movies influenced his own
filmmaking and once upon a time in
Hollywood
Ricky Dalton goes to Rome to shoot a few
movies with director Sergio Corbucci and
antonio margheriti a Corbucci directed a
real movie called Django which would go
on to influence Tarantino's Django
Unchained meanwhile the name Margaret a
pops up an inglorious basterds tequila
lay Antonio Madigan ap there are other
references to Basterds early on in the
movie a scene showing a movie in which
Rick Dalton burns a bunch of Nazis alive
with a flamethrower will give you
flashbacks to Tarantino's film and it
foreshadows the history altering course
ahead the camera also pans over to comic
books
sergeant fury and kid Colt outlaw
Tarantino has cited sergeant fury as an
influence on inglorious basterds
once upon a time in Hollywood opens with
a clip from the fictional rick dalton
series bounty law a man is shot and
falls off a roof at which point he lets
out a big Wilhelm scream this particular
scream effect has become something of an
inside joke in the movie industry and it
pops up in several other Tarantino films
bounty law takes place on a set called
melody ranch it's the same set used in
Tarantino's Django Unchained Rick also
guest stars in an episode of a real 1960
show called the FBI the FBI Rick plays a
character named Michael Murtagh
originally played by Burt Reynolds
Reynolds is supposedly one of the
inspirations for Dalton Tarantino
originally planned to cast Reynolds as
George spawn before his untimely death
that role ended up going to Bruce Dern
and speaking of durin he once appeared
on Lancer the real series that is
featured heavily in the film Tarantino
likes to cast the same people over and
over again in a bounty law scene you'll
notice a quick cameo from actor Michael
Madsen Madsen has popped up in many of
Tarantino's movies perhaps most famously
as mr. blonde and Reservoir Dogs another
Tarantino regular Tim Roth was supposed
to play JC brings Butler his scene was
cut but his name remains in the credits
while Tarantino alums Bruce Willis and
uma Thurman aren't in the movie their
daughters Rumer Willis and Maya Hawke
each play a small role Kurt Russell
plays a stunt coordinator named Randy he
also portrayed stuntman Mike a stunt
driver turned killer in 2007's death
Proof stuntwoman zoë bell pops up to
fire cliff Boothe after he beats up
Bruce Lee fail also starred in death
Proof in addition she was Thurman stunt
double in the Kill Bill movies and a
stunt double for both Diane Kruger and
Melanie Lauren in Inglourious Basterds
speaking of Bruce Lee his influences
popped up in Tarantino's work before in
Kill Bill Vol 1 The Green Hornet theme
plays during a sequence in which the
bride played by Thurman arrives in Tokyo
and once upon a time in Hollywood
cliff refers to Leah's Cato the name of
his character in Green Hornet Lea was
associated with Roman Polanski and
Sharon Tate in real life and he even
gave each of them martial arts lessons
while the film centers around the Manson
family murders the notorious cult leader
shows up only briefly in the movie Damon
Harriman who plays Charles Manson will
also play Manson in the upcoming second
season of the Netflix series mind Hunter
Manson arrives at Tate's home in a
Twinkie truck which he reportedly drove
in real life as well in the first scene
we see of Manson's family their dumpster
diving outside a grocery store you can
hear them singing a song called I'll
never say never - always a real song
written by Manson while singing the
girls are standing under a mural
depicting James Dean on the poster first
last movie ever 1956 is giant
there are numerous references to shows
movies and culture of the era if you
look closely a bus stop advertises
Fright Night a horror TV series that
some of the characters are watching
later in the film the VOC theater is
showing the 68th film the night they
raided Minsky's Rick appears on a real
60 show called hullabaloo
singing a song called the green door by
Jim Lowe the radio advertises the
illustrated man by Ray Bradbury and the
drive-in theater is playing the 1968
film pretty poison a lot of Hollywood
legends loom large over this movie a few
of them come together during a sequence
at the Playboy Mansion the scene is
partially narrated by Steve McQueen
played by Damian Lewis McQueen was one
of many real-life influences for Rick
Dalton like Dalton McQueen started his
career doing Western TV shows unlike
Dalton McQueen got out of TV and ended
up becoming a major movie star in fact
Dalton talks about auditioning for a
role in The Great Escape a 1963 war
movie that would define McQueen's career
using innovative CGI the movie actually
inserts the Caprio into a real scene
from the movie also the playboy party
are members of the Mamas and the Papas
Michelle Phillips and Mama Cass a
montage in the movie is set to their
classic song California dreamin on the
evening of the murders we see a copy of
the sheet music for the Mamas in the
Papa song straight-shooter
this same song could be heard in the
movies trailer in real life the sheet
music for straight-shooter was found on
the piano when the bodies were first
discovered at Polanski's house movie
includes a stunning history bending
twist in which the manson family members
break into Rick Dalton's house instead
of Sharon Tate's house and hates life is
spared however there are still real
details from the murders incorporated
into the scene among them when they
first break into the house Tex Watson
tells cliff I'm the devil and I'm here
to do the devil's business Watson
reportedly said this upon breaking into
Tate's house that night when preparing
to play Tate actress Margot Robbie
worked closely with several members of
the Tate family an interview on today
Robbie said Sharon's sister Deborah gave
her some of Sharon's jewelry to wear in
the movie the night of the murders Tate
and her friends went to dinner at a
Mexican restaurant called el coyote in
the movie when she walks into the
restaurant he notices a porn movie
premiere happening down the
three this was likely happening at the
eros theater which at the time was an
adult movie theater just around the
corner from el coyote a today the eros
theater is the new Beverly cinema a
movie theater oh my none other than
Quentin Tarantino that's not the only
theater to pop up throughout the movie
Tarantino pays tribute to many of the
great movie theaters of his childhood in
Los Angeles to such theaters include the
Bruin where Tate goes to watch her movie
the wrecking crew at one point cliff
drives by the iconic Cinerama both
theaters still exist today there are
many iconic la locations throughout Rick
meets producer Marvin Shores at Musso
and Frank's grill which has been around
since 1919 the crew filmed on-location
in the restaurant even let them use the
dishes the restaurant would have used in
the 1960s at one point we see Cliff
picking up Rick from the Columbia
Pictures lot Columbia which is now part
of Sony produced once upon a time in
Hollywood all the studio's wall you can
see a giant poster for the Barbra
Streisand classic funny girl which the
studio released in 1968 another famous
location can actually be spotted in
plenty of other TV shows and movies when
cliff Rick and Rick's new wife returned
from Rome they walked past a blue mosaic
tile wall in LAX it's the same wall we
see Jackie moved past in the opening
credits of Jackie Brown many movies and
TV shows have been shot in front of
these famous walls it popped up in an
episode of Mad Men and in 1967 s the
Graduate another movie that
revolutionized Hollywood during this
time and an additional throwback to the
Graduate cliff blast mrs. Robinson in
his car when he first encounters
pussycat cliff is in an alga mayshen of
many famous Hollywood stuntmen including
Gary Kent stuntman who actually
encountered Charles Manson on spawn
ranch but the part of his storyline in
which he picks up a hitchhiker who ends
up being a member of the Manson family
is reminiscent of late Beach Boys member
Dennis Wilson in real life
Wilson picked up two hitchhikers in
Malibu who ended up being two members of
the
and family when rick and cliff are
together in italy rick talks about how
he needs to downsize in his life he
mentions possibly moving into a condo in
Toluca Lake a neighborhood in the San
Fernando Valley Toluca Lake also played
a prominent role in pulp fiction call
him a partner Toluca Lake there is one
element that while small ties nearly
every single Tarantino movie together a
fake cigarette brand called a red apple
they pop up a few times in Pulp Fiction
and Kill Bill volume 1 the bride walks
past an advertisement for them they're
also in hirschberg's pocket in
Inglourious Basterds you can even see a
pack of them in the hateful eight set in
the post-civil war era the brand pops up
in two instances and once upon a time in
Hollywood at one point cliff holds on to
a pack while smoking outside Rick's
trailer then during the movies and
credits scene Rick doesn't add for the
company despite smoking a different
brand throughout the movie in it he
mentions that red apple has been around
since 1862
several new fictional brands were also
added to the Tarantino universe
including old Chattanooga Beer and
cliffs fridge and the dog food Wolf's
tooth since Tarantino grew up during the
60s he also added a few personal touches
to the film cliff drives a Carmen Gia
just like Tarantino's father did and
some of the props in Rick's house are
from Tarantino's personal collection
specifically the Hopalong Cassidy cups
was there anything we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]